rely so thank you very much for the
invitation I'm very happy to be here and
thanks for staying for the entire
weekend for the final talk of the entire
workshops once a week so this this last
talk I think maybe this was done on
purpose because I think this is going to
be a slightly a slight bit more
empirical than some of the stuff that
we've been seeing but I hope that in
this talk and some of the sort of
preliminary results that i'll be
presenting it might inspire some further
discussion either during the workshops
the remainder of several months that are
left or even during this talk itself and
so what I'm going to be talking about is
a problem I guess that could be called
interactive learning of some modular
mixtures which is essentially a problem
that has come up with the utilization of
sahaja functions for a variety of
applications and machine learning
problems so let's just give a brief
summary first of what we're going to be
talking about is first of all hopefully
convincing ourselves that sub modularity
are useful classes of functions to
represent concepts like diversity in
heterogeneity in complexity and
information and and that they're useful
variety of a variety of problems in
machine learning a data science and then
I'll sort of you know some of the things
that might group it and I have been
working on for the past many actually
many years now have has been to
essentially try to come up with ways
that one can reduce the sub-module
function and appropriate sub-module
function for a particular application in
machine learning data science and that
has led to the desire to try to learn
the submerged or function somehow and so
what I'll do is is discuss some some
ways that people have both theoretically
and practically try to acquire a good
sub major function and what does good
mean and how do you acquire it and how
do you apply it and that'll be the
second part of the talk and then the
last part of the talk is probably the
most preliminary and that's discussing
some initial results and algorithms for
interactive learning of modular
functions and I guess if there any
questions at any time please field
interrupt me this is Friday afternoon
everybody is very tired
I'm greatly appreciative of all of you
staying here this late I also want to
acknowledge that this is work with
students of mine kai way when we buy and
risha buyer and I think this the
interactive so modular some was learning
is a modular functions stuff is
primarily Kai's stuff so a lot of the
stuff actually I'm thinking is not
previously published so if you ask me if
I have a paper for this the answer is
not yet okay so let's begin three parts
submodular functions and data science so
I think probably my guess is that most
people in this audience especially if
you've seen the tutorials that happens a
few weeks ago on so much of functions
and she's learning most people are
familiar with so much of functions and
basically the major function has been
you know they've been used and they've
been studied for probably over a hundred
years now in a variety of different
communities coming from you know lattice
carries on Dedic and lattice series
starting in h late eighteen hundreds and
also in the economics community people
like Samuel change so on and so forth
but basically the idea is that you have
there's suitable lean functions and you
have some underlying finite gram set V
and you have a function that map's from
all possible subsets of e to the real
and so these are suitably lien functions
but there's fruit of boolean functions
that satisfies where the properties
namely this modular set of inequalities
which says in one hand on one hand that
if you take any subset a and B that the
value of the sets a and B must have the
following relationship namely that the
value of a plus the value of b is
greater than equal to the value of the
Union plus the value of the intersection
so that's one of the standard
definitions of some modularity which
some people like some people don't like
the second perhaps much more intuitive
definition of some larger functions is
the notion of diminishing returns again
you have discrete set function and in
this particular case you think about how
does the incremental gain of an element
that you don't yet have in your set
change as the context in which you're
evaluating grows mainly in terms of
inclusive wise growth so here you have a
set a and B visas website of a
beez consider the super context of a and
a submodular function is one where the
game which is this quantity here this is
how much how valuable v is in the
context of a basically is larger in the
smaller context so the smaller the
context the larger or the no less the
gain is than in the larger context so
this is this is the standard notion of
diminishing returns essentially that
says that the more you have the less
valuable anything you don't have become
that's so modular sub-module functions
can be described like all good concepts
in computer science using balls and urns
and basically this sort of gives the
intuition that so much of functions are
good at diversity function so here's an
example of a sub major function that I
use the balls in there and not by the
quantity of balls in the Iran but rather
by the diversity of colors of the balls
in the air and so on the left the left
hand side you've got two colors so the
value is 2 when you add a blue ball the
value increases by one because you you
have increased the diversity whereas on
the right hand side that you start off
with the value of 31 at least one of the
balls is blue and when you add a new
blow ball in the value has not increased
diminishing returns property and
basically whenever you have a superset
it's never the case that the value can
increase with the sub-module function
your standard but of course there are
many many difference of major functions
and I think what's interesting about the
modularity not just in machine learning
but across all of the fields of science
is that it's been discovered
independently many many times and there
are as many equal there are deeply as
many different names for some modularity
they're equally as many different
definitions of some modularity and
correspondingly there are a lot of
different classes or sub classes of sub
module functions but you know at the
outset look very different but actually
are quite all lie within the same family
but whatever whatever sort of subclasses
of modular functions you use they're all
sort of useful at representing things
like complexity and heterogeneity or
diversity and in fact I'm
sometimes we like to call them sort of
measures of abstract combinatorial
independence because they're generalized
information your eight functions you
know entropy this about your function
you can actually talk about in some
sense combinatorial independence based
on certain equality's or inequalities
being true amongst the measure maybe the
similar function measure so other than
sort of their naturalness to a variety
problems in terms of data signs and
being information functions the other
nice property about some other functions
is that they're usually sort of the
limit that you can go without things
becoming hopelessly impossible so like
whenever you're trying to do
combinatorial optimization problems
traditionally combinatorial optimization
has had basically additive or linear
functions which prefer that sort of
judged the quality of a given solution
of a comet or the problem like grass
cutting or graphics classic problem
where the quality of the edges or the
judgment of the edges is basically the
sum of the edge weights it's additive in
the edges but there are lot of other
comment oriole problems that you might
want to solve where you have costs of
the sub objects in the resulting
solution sets interact in some way and
you could think of these as a sub-module
organization or constraints the modular
optimization problems like on the left
you've got a maximization problem
subject to a set of constraints on the
right you have a minimization problem
the constraints could be for example
that these solutions that has to abide
by the sets cuts in some underlying
graph which might not have anything to
do with the any length of module
function or on equation 5 you might have
a partitioning problem a data
partitioning problem or a packing
problem or covering problem where the
judgment of the partition is governed by
some sub module function embedded within
this this function J so this is the
class of all partitions so basically
over the past decade I mean maybe you
know again many of you familiar with
this maybe some of you are not there has
been a wealth of results showing that
there seems to be you know whenever it's
the case that sub modularity is either
directly or indirectly related to the
problem it's not it's possible to get
good approximation guarantees usually
multiplicative
without losing computational
tractability and practically
practicality so oftentimes the
algorithms are sometimes their linear
sometimes they're and login oftentimes
they're very cheap and usable so this is
our interest in them is that they seem
they seem to be allow you to do a lot
without much computational cost and
their natural so here's a here's another
slide so so in that that has been
collected from looking at learning
curves across across a variety of
different machine learning instances and
what each of one of these curves
correspond to is the accuracy of a
machine learning classifier as a
function of the amount of training data
that class flyer is allowed to train on
and it's jeff's on so here's like a
classic one banco and guerrilla one
which shows that as between gate
increases in the x-axis in this cases in
the number of millions of words that are
trained the performance goes up on a
test set but on the other hand there's
sort of a diminishing returns like
effect and before you say well wait a
second is have you controls with
complexity in sometimes this is these
are really in sometimes non non
parametric classifiers because in these
experiments most of these experiments
the experimenter have to have controls
or they've controlled for the complexity
of the classifier so that it's not like
for example you're reaching some
underlying limit of the capacity or the
complexity of the class of classifiers
that you're using to learn the function
so all of these things have this
property basically this dimension
returns promptly and so there's this
another additional definition of sub
modularity which basically says that if
it's the case that you have this
dimension returns property for all
permutations and that's a necessary and
sufficient condition for some modularity
so what this definition and these kinds
of empirical results which were done
completely independently of the notion
of modularity to guess is that there's
probably some sort of similarity going
on in data in large data sets and these
days were faced with big data problems
and if it's possible to get a subset of
data may be a course that like so
set of data that represents the whole
set that should be useful because it
would significantly perhaps appreciably
reduce the complexity in dealing with
lunch data that's because you're not
dealing with redundancies inherent in
the ledge data set so that's the idea of
summarization the audit summarization
which has become a sort of catch-all
term in recently in the machine learning
community to sort of correspond to
taking a very large set and reducing it
down to its core some way or another so
summarization problem would be for
example getting a very large data set
looking at its value from say for
example at sub-module function and then
reducing it while make making the data
set size small but it's keeping the
value to some other function large now
that's something that actually can be
done but a lot of actually standard
problems and so that's the modular
functions help with in machine learning
and data science including I mean this
there's been a lot of discussions on
active learning in fact oftentimes one
when one has active learning of problems
wants to choose one wants to choose
samples to label or to query that aren't
redundant and there are sort of hybrid
adaptive batch active learning because
of various different constraints in a
real world problem where you want to
simultaneously query the labels of a
batch or a mini batch of samples
simultaneously and it would be wasteful
if we were to do that for you to query
redundant samples when you're doing an
adaptive approach maybe that's not as
important because it automatically
adapts to remove the redundancies but as
soon as you start doing batch active
learning so much larity comes into play
because that's the classes of functions
that can help to eliminate redundancy
but there are a lot of other
applications in machine learning where
so much light is being used like feature
selection and model selection and so on
and so forth kata petitioning so here
the main the main problems that I'm
going to be talking about today are are
sort of summarization starvation ideas
where you have a large collection of
documents or a large collection of
images or videos or any or data maybe
you have a large training set for
machine learning system and you want to
reduce it a priori before you actually
unleash your massive piles of GPU and
deep models on it to train for
several months and so that's the idea
training data set reduction which
removes redundancy and improves training
time but you can also imagine maybe test
set reduction because one of the other
things that happens when you remove
redundancy is you also remove by us
there may be some underlying concepts
and in a data set which is
underrepresented from multiplicity
perspective but when you summarize it
since it's rare this is a rare
subpopulation when in the community of
data that it gets preserved because it's
that you know removing that would
significantly would not remove
redundancy remove diversity and there
are some other applications in genomic
summarization and drug trials where you
want to choose a subpopulation
individual say to participate in a drug
trial so that you're sure sure that your
drug trial is representative of the
population ultimately that you would
like to unleash this drug on to so just
a little bit of definition so more
definition so a function is said to be
super modular a function G a super
modular it's negative G sub modular a
function is that's really modular if
it's both sub module and super modular a
function is said to be normalized if its
value at the empty set is equal to zero
and in fact all normalized modular
functions can be written in this way
basically they're additives the value of
a set is equal to the sum of the values
individual items and so therefore
modular functions can be seen as vectors
in RV reviews the total set of items and
there's another little bit of notation
that I want to define which is the gain
this is the the addition that that
element a provides to the value of the
function f in the context of B which is
just a difference for just notational
you can just fit d plus a which means B
Union a and then there's the notion of
monotone functions which basically says
that when you add something the value
can never decrease and lastly just I'll
probably say this but whenever you're
talking about a normalized monotone non
decreasing so much the function that's
referred to often
Polly major functions called a Polly
major functions various reasons okay so
there's a particular class of some logic
functions I'm going to be talking about
which are which are you think of the
future based functions and these are
useful in in many machine million
context context because of the fact that
there's been so much work on future
engineering machine learning problems
where you have data items and you sort
of in some sometimes embed the data in
some new dimensional space or use a set
of features and every whenever you do
instructed predictions so they've each
features could be anything they could be
in grams in sentences or they could be
grasped heuristics in India if their
various different types graph but
feature-based sub-module functions take
the following form where for each each
feature you have a sort of a submodular
function that features specific
submodular functions piece of you which
measures the information in a subset X
with respect to that feature you and
then you take non-negative some where
over each of these feature based
functions to get a parametric family of
the larger function param tries by these
mixture coefficients you think of them
as importance weights or so on and so
forth in fact one particular subclass of
the future based functions that that we
often consider in our work or instances
where each one of these fees consists of
a concave function composed with a
modular function which are sub modular
functions but for the purposes of this
talk that's that's not that critical so
I'm going to probably skip over that
this so so the next part of the talk let
by the way so again if so any questions
I know this is really pretty simple so
far but if there any questions please
please stop me at any time so the next
talk part of the talk is also going to
be reviewing because it's going to
review the ways in which people in the
past have found sub modularity for their
applications in machine learning so the
question is how do you find rights of
modular function so one way that people
including ourselves have done this is to
essentially hand design and given some
larger function for a particular task
because you know about it because you
know you have some domain knowledge and
you can
okay I I have these features and I want
these weights because I know how
important these given features are for
my application and that actually
surprisingly enough in practice works
pretty well for various summarization
problems already with it without having
actually having a need to to sort of do
any sort of hand adjustments of these or
sorry any automatic automated machine
learning like adjustment to be to the
function itself but on the other hand it
doesn't work as well as what one can do
if one allows us to learn the samaja
function little one approach to learn a
submodular function would be to learn it
unconstrained Italy so over over all
possible sub-module functions now i'm
going to say in a minute that in fact so
much functions have 2 to the N where n n
is equal to the size of V the ground set
there's two to the N independent degrees
of freedom so that's a that's a
complicated learning problem potentially
because it's a lot of parameters you
have to learn and I'll summarize some of
the results on that so in order to avoid
this this explosion number parameters
you can learn the sub-module function
constrain Utley based on some sort of
degree restriction or one can learn it
and what we're going to talk about today
based on a sort of parametric family and
then the other thing we're going to talk
about today of course is the learning
paradigm like that we learn in batch or
passive or online or adaptive or
interactive which is what we really
would like to do for variety of reasons
so the first thing I'd like to mention
is of course is that you know why does
submodular functions why do submodular
functions leave in a cone of dimension
through to the end so it's pretty easy
to show actually you can take any you
could take any sub module function
that's stripped so what I mean by strict
you can think of this as a form of
literate smiths and indiscreet and for
some other functions but basically take
any submerged a function where this
inequality the Sumerian equality is true
strictly for all a and B and it's easy
to find so much friendships that have
that property in fact the square root of
the cardinality function is
districts of modular function and you
can show that based on the [ __ ] you
we're very trivially and when you have
any strict sub-module function you
compute this quantity epsilon which is
the smallest gap the smallest non zero
gap between F of a and it's a B and s
are the Union possesses the intersection
and you take the minimum over all non
comparable sets non comparable means
that a is neither a subset of B norbies
a subset of a because otherwise it can
trivially zero so you have epsilon and
epsilon since it's that modular is going
to be strictly greater than zero and
then you define another quantity so for
every subset a you choose some epsilon
which is greater than 0 but no more than
epsilon have and you define a new
function f tilde where you make epsilon
you make basically 2 to the n
independent movements in in space and
since these movements are independent
there there there if not they don't live
in some sub manifold and so therefore
there are just by the simple example to
the n degrees of freedom in a sub-module
function so this is really potentially
from the deflector of learning bad news
right because it means that to learn you
know if you have 2 to the N parameters
you probably need a lot of training date
a lot of samples but there's this
remarkable result I still think it's
remarkable this was a result it was
originally shown by of us and Shriver
back in the late 70s and early 80s but
then recently there's been some also
what I think a remarkable results which
is that minimizing the sub-module
function can be done in polynomial time
and polynomial number of queries to the
samaja function in fact the most recent
results and this is this is quite
amazing that you can minimize the
Samadhi function where you only ask the
samaja function for a value basically in
less than n cubed times like n squared
log and basically so basically all of
that stuff all of that independent
degree freedom from the perspective of
needing to do so much a function is
irrelevant is redundant for minimization
because I don't care how much additional
computer you do you're only asking for
very little and as n goes to infinity
if the amount of information you're
asked them about that so much of
function goes to zero because the supply
ship function itself has to the nth
degree of freedom so what does it say
about then learning the submerged
function because maybe if we can
minimize and following on that time
despite the fact that there's so many
degrees of freedom maybe learning is
good as it's nice so well what is
learning mean so there have been a
number of results primarily I mean Nina
Falcon who's not here today house
because of this was one of the first
person to do this but basically the
question is well what do we mean by
learn and what do we mean by learning
well and so how do we judge goodness so
one way of judging goodness might be to
be multiplicatively good so let's assume
that this time choose of module function
f got here and we're interested in some
approximation this guy there and
goodness means that the F tilde that
we've learnt has this property for LA or
maybe we care about it having that
property at some fraction 1 minus beta
of the two to the end point based on
some probability distribution PR okay
and and that's actually i'll talk about
this in the next slide but that's
basically the essence of pee mak
learning but you know goodness also
might be measured this is sort of a
multiplicative goodness or probabilistic
multiplicative goodness goodness also
might be an additive might be measured
additively where you want your
approximation to be close they do
excellent close in some expected p norm
so again you have some probability
dispersion you want this error could be
small
so the pmac setting is was probably one
of the first learning settings to the
considered for sub-modules learning and
and basically there's some it's it's
it's just like a pack setting it's a
distribution free setting so it learns
in the worst case and basically there's
some training data and basically with
some probability 1 minus delta which is
the probably we are approximately
correct but we're also relaxing a little
bit by being approximately mostly
correct because we don't have to be good
on all on we have to be good on all by 1
minus beta fraction at the point so beta
you know betta adds a little bit more
flexibility and so Nina and nick harvey
showed both an algorithm that gets rid
of an approximate e and also a hardness
of and the one-third for this problem
which which is actually kind of
upsetting in certain ways because it
it's not a particularly good result
meaning that you can't do better than
try to approximate this function
probably time with accuracy better than
enter the one-third now maybe there's a
bit of good news which is that well this
is a bit of a stringent learning setting
for two reasons one because its
distribution free and also because it's
multiplicatively you want it to be
multiplicatively good so more recently
there's been some results by Feldman
qatari and vondrak who showed that if
you in particular the key thing that
they relaxes with distribution free
assumption that if you know the
distribution is uniform they gave pack
like it's not fully pack is it's not
distribution free but it's a pack like
given and distribution learning results
where if you have if there's some
unknown submodular function and you have
uniformly at random samples of the
subset and evaluations with sub-module
function there exists an algorithm that
does have low error and it runs in
up to log factors n squared + 2 to the 1
over epsilon to the fourth power so
we're but it produces a resulting learn
function and it's epsilon good in this 2
norm sense so this particular result Oh
was it clear what the multiplicative
there was no matter this was not
multiplicative so this is the additive
in the 2 norm sensor this this guy here
so under the next slide I didn't fully
follow what probability distribution
over is being induced by and what's the
function f like how is the truth being
defined yeah so so there's some an
underlying probability distribution in
the distribution free case you don't
know what it is and basically you have
samples from this distribution and also
as measured by that distribution you
need to be good at one so it's the same
distribution you'll need to be good at
one minus beta at a fraction women's
data of the point because if it's if
it's a uniform distribution then it's
exactly one must fail at times to the V
good and then the values that we observe
our actual realizations of a submodular
function maybe with some nice right no
this is the noise reset case so there's
some reason working like andreas is
sitting is something we can work on
learning so much linear on singers also
done some work on learning which i'm not
actually get listening to talk about the
noise case there is no not sort of the
cream agnostics version there i have
whatever samples i have and then i try
to trick the best of model of like a yes
no I'm there's some agnostic you know
yawn and until then have some results in
a plastic case but they're agnostic from
the perspective of you may not have
noisy estimates but the function that
your class that you're learning from is
not so modular
some form of agnostic like that that
could be seen its like a submerged or
projection like approach but in any
event so yeah in fact here's here's one
of the they're agnostic results which
basically has F being not necessarily
sub modular and you can still learn with
complexities both sample and
computational complexities of pulling in
and 2 to the 1 over epsilon squared
samples and then it's actually very very
recently well actually last year I guess
the papers been out on archives for a
couple of years the last night it was
published there's they came out with a
pee Mak a very positive pee Mak learning
result again but it wasn't fully pee Mak
it was the distribution known to be
uniform case that can learn with a G
function of 1 plus gamma ok and again
it's the same kind of result it's 1 it's
2 to the 1 over some poly in the
additive approximation epsilon and that
this approximation g ok so what we're
going to do then is sort of still back
away from these hard learning settings
because basically you know none of these
learning results ask for the to learn
over a parametric subfamilies of modular
functions are basically saying okay
we've got some point you can learn over
all possible points into the end in
order to the end that are so modular
whereas perhaps a simpler form of
learning i mean in fact if it was
definitely simple simply form learning
would be to have a parametric family
like a feature-based function where the
thing that the only thing that's learned
are these coefficients mainly the
mixture coefficients so in some sense
it's severely restricting the learning
process but as a result may be improved
the other thing about the pmac setting
is that pee Mak is in some sense
oblivious to what points are Lunt other
than saying that you need to learn on 1
minus beta fraction of them to the point
but other it doesn't care which 1-8 a
fraction I mean the distribution some
sense does that but as long as according
to that distribution you do it and in
the distribution free case it will will
learn and that that is again not as
motivated for for example summarization
applications as the next learning
setting that you might imagine and this
is an easier learning setting where
basically it's a parametric learning
setting where you care to find the
parameters W so that then if you
maximize your learnt from your learned
function or maybe you don't exactly
maximize that you're approximately
maximize using the greedy algorithm is
one might wonder if again p said it
should be the case that that if you
evaluate that resulting set that you
computed from the learned function it's
good with respect to the optimum for
some alpha ganti okay so it's basically
you know in some sense analogous to the
way conditional likelihood compares to
say unconditional exit where when you're
doing conditional likely or what
sometimes calls in some sense to screw
initiative training you don't need to
learn everything about a probability
distribution we need to know perhaps
that's where its boundaries are in fact
a lot of the discussions about learning
are all about that question
information age but yeah this is this is
bad notation so H is truth in this case
and Lenny's many to six fish per second
so um yeah sorry about that so H I was
changing notation mid talk or mid mid
preparing so this should be a station
bus should be f so f is truth so the B
that's returned by the learned function
should be good with the sector truth
ok so this sort of was the motivation
behind max margin learning of sub
modular functions which was stuff that
was originally done a couple years ago
and basically it precedes as follows
we've got a training set f of subsets
right and in fact these they don't have
to be subsets of the same underlying
grounds that you could imagine that the
notation doesn't say this but you can
imagine having a series of ground sets
VT and a subset of VT and each one of
the subsets is sort of meant to be
representative of the whole service rep
is meant to be good or rep it meant to
be something that has high value if
you're familiar with nature it's
basically you can think of this is in
some sense learning and may Troi by
having subsets that are independent and
so what the Maximizer learning approach
says is that for each one of your
training samples and for every possible
subset a you want your learnt function
to value your training sample greater
than any other subset a up to some loss
which is basically how bad a is with
respect to s and in fact if the losses
is basically if a is a good surrogate
for s then basically the loss is zero
and of course it doesn't matter you can
have this could be inequality otherwise
if a is a is quite bad at representing s
then then you want this to be much
greater than that and that's exactly the
max sort of the structured max margin
approach that was done in machine
learning community starting maybe 17
years ago or so and so that's I think
they just kind of just said this that
you want this to be small whenever a is
closed and want this to be large
whenever is bad and so you can turn this
into an optimization problem where one
wants to find the set of mixture
coefficients where w some constraint set
which could be the positive ortant you
know basically you're you're finding
again
is this you're trying to learn this
vector W such that these margin
constraints are as satisfied as possible
and then you have a regularizer and then
there's some underlying loss which is
whenever it's the case that the Martian
constraints are not satisfied you suffer
some loss and this could be either
logistic loss or hinge lawsuit or some
other sort of approach now this this
might be convex this might be a convex
optimization problem certainly the
regular kind of regular is convex and if
usual convex loss function L and then
that's that looks good the difficulty
here and this is the difficulty that
we've had is this particular problem
here which is the law segmented infants
so it's the maximization if it is the
case that everything is linear in w
which it often is and in fact when W
when it's a mixer for module functions
everything's linear the whole thing is
is is contacts which is great the
problem is however have you go i should
also before i talk about the problem i
should talk about how it actually works
so the comparison between hand selecting
a sub-module function versus doing a
better hand selection of a submerged
function versus automatic learning of so
much of friendships this is in a
standard document summarization task
which is used in the natural language
processing community quite a bit and so
there seems to be at least in
empirically a real advantage to actually
learning as opposed to hands that's fine
the selected function for producing
summarization tasks so this is actually
a fairly standard task and there was a
standard way of evaluating summarization
long before we came along and and tried
this approach for this task and these
are some other results on image
summarization it's a lot of results so
let me just sort of try to summarize the
results so basically these are the lurch
results according to various strategies
and various different loss functions
which I'll talk about in a second these
are the best ones and these are all of
the results corresponding to hand
specified results
sorry Han specified sub-module functions
and these are cheating results those are
those are sort of lightspeed we can't
expect to do any better than that and
you can see that again the learning some
other function approaches tend to work
better the blue ones work better than
the green ones ok so the difficulty as I
was mentioning the two slides ago is in
this law segmented entrance from where
it's actually hard it's hard depending
on what the loss is and it's in some
cases one can for example come up with a
modular losses by loss i mean this
particular last year its basis a lots of
how good is a it as a surrogate for f
the chain example and is modular and
non- then basically everything becomes
sub-module optimization then we can use
the greedy algorithm we get the standard
1-1 every guarantee and things are much
nicer however that's that's the modulus
is not a very natural law so much more
natural loss is is to use something akin
to some constant minus the truth of my
dysfunction and there are some cases
where you know you might be able to get
to choose some larger function in other
cases maybe you might be able to run
human experiments to get some query of F
that's going to get back into the
interactive stuff we'll talk about in a
minute but this leads to a difference of
samaja optimization problem which I'll
I'll talk about in a second but these
these were this difference of some
larger optimization problem is not
insurmountable which I'll also talk
about in a minute one of the things I do
want to talk about that is currently
insurmountable and that motivates the
interactive approach is the following
whenever you're trying to collect
training data like imagine you're trying
to build the summarizer an image surmise
or some sort of image collection of
these days consist of tens maybe
hundreds of thousands of images probably
in every one of our phone and if it was
the case that you wanted remembering the
max margin approach to to gather
training data what one would need is to
say here's a very very large question of
images and then here's a summary so the
question is how is it feasible to
actually get summaries as instances of
training data in all of the instances of
training
image summarization systems we use in
the past it's always been the case that
the large collection is rather small and
so it's still feasible to get training
data but as soon as you get to large
image collections it'd be kind of
suitable and then I guess there's
another another task which is you know
whatever we're doing training data
summarization for machine learning
system it's computationally infeasible
to ask the machine learning system to
find the very summery that we want to
give it that's the circularity so that
also is an infeasible or a circularity
problem we thing that we can ask it to
solve the problem we're trying to solve
so the question is what do you do that's
where interactive summarization function
to play so this is sort of this is now
sort of familiar to everybody I think
the idea is that if it's in the case of
image summarization the Samana line
image collection we have an interactive
summarizer who then produces a candidate
summary of images and then the human or
the machine learning system then judges
that summary and provides feedback over
its form back to the summarizer and that
starts this process in time now the
questions of course are you know in this
setting what how do you parameter eyes
the summarizer in an hour in this work
we're going to talk about parameterizing
in terms of these mixtures of sub
modular functions so really everything
is everything that's being learnt is
this w sector a really important
question and that's where the novelty of
the interactive stuff that I will be
talking about lies is what type of
feedback are we going to ask from the
user in general you want this humans job
to be as easy as possible you want to be
able to get accurate but perhaps noisy
or distorted feedback from the user the
third question is how do you produce
summaries because that might you know
this interactive summary needs to
produce with something that itself
potentially could be a comet oriole
khanna truly difficult problem and then
how do you update the parameters once
we've got feedback this is the whole
history of some reason feedback that
we've got
then we had to we judge the quality how
do we know what it's doing well this
sort of begs questions regret so here's
a slightly more instantiated version of
this so this becomes a comment Oriole
optimization problem where at this stage
here we basically want to maximize one
possibility would be to maximize this
the current sub-module function or some
sort of current something
okay so so we were sort of inspired by
yi seong and Carlos new song and use and
Carlos Christians work from 2011 which
was linnaeus of modular bandits and the
basic idea was that at each round
there's the money online ground set
which is revealed to the algorithm so
again the ground sets need not be the
same from one time step to the next time
step and there it's always the case that
there is still some underlying concept
space you and the way that objects are
embedded in concept spaces by the set of
sub modular function so if you if you
value a particular object you can look
at samajh evaluations of the vector
which is this and that sort of is the
value of that object and then the gain
which is how good the object is you know
a is in the context of cafe which is
this is represented by this profiles
profile of gains for each one of the sub
modular components and so in this
particular setting the algorithm chooses
some subset 80 of BTM I'm sorry about
the typos here this should be super
script and 80 is is ordered in this
fashion from it's a size K summary and
what the agent does or which could be
the human and the machine learning
system does it's provides a reward
vector one for each one of these
elements in the summary so the idea and
the critical thing here is that you're
providing a summary but you're providing
a summary in order so it's a sordid
summary and then you present these items
to the user you can think of it as a
list of web pages and the rewards you
get back are the clicked set of pages if
it's a set of images you provide a set
of images in order and the reward you
get back are those images that the user
chose or if it's been this is where
we're sort of motivating why this may
not be appropriate for some of the
problems we're trying to solve if it's a
machine learning summary somehow the
Machine learner has to come back and
choose and rewards you for some subset
of the of the some rain that you
provided to it
and so basically the agent provides this
reward vector which is a length K vector
and the assumptions in order to get the
regard band is basically that the
rewards are independent random variables
with a mean equal to this dot products
it's the dot product between some sorts
a realizable case of some w star and the
dot product between w star and the gain
vector okay and then they define regret
in this way so it's the difference
between the best set of summaries
obtained in hindsight and the summaries
that are produced by D algorithm now the
critical thing here I think that one
should realize is that because things
are independent the expected values can
go inside here right so it's really the
sum of the expected rewards are supposed
to expected some of the awards and
that's thanks to the independence
assumptions for that reason they're able
to provide a regret bound of square root
of T so it's basically square root of t
KS the size of the summary and then size
of use is the number of features or the
number of composites that's the modular
components so what we wanted to study
we're going to say well well first of
all the independence assumptions may not
be realistic because it's not
necessarily the case when it's a human
somewhere you presented a list of images
that the rewards are going to be truly
independent they're going to be highly
dependent I think certainly in the
machine learning system setting there
can be highly dependent and then
secondly the need for the agent to
provide feedback on every increment is
is kind of an arduous task for certain
settings for the human it's if it's a
let's say it's a 1 billion image
collection and you're reducing it to 1
million images you can't ask the human
to provide a score for every one of
those 1 million images in some order if
it's a 10 billion size training sample
you can't expect a machine learning
systems to some system how provide into
to run that machine learning system and
all of those 1 million samples
incrementally so that defeats the whole
purpose so what we'd like to do is see
definitely alleviate the number of bits
of feedback that we actually get back
from the agent so in fact the best sort
of thing you know to sort of be a we are
sort of inspired by Facebook is it would
be good to say when there's a summary
just to get a thumbs up or thumbs down
you know it's a binary feedbacks or
maybe there's a five-point likert scale
of some sort or even maybe a real value
a scalar real-valued feedback where we
get you know sort of made it evaluates
if the humans can be modeled as before
motor function we get that to the
modular value so it is it it is because
it is still in the Bandit setting that
sense we don't get the function we just
get the value that it was or the
distorted value with a noisy value so
this sort of this this is an hour
algorithm for optimizing this it's
online comment oriole sampling and so
what we start with and basically there's
T realm and let's just start this inside
out so it at step 6 we produce a summary
which maximizes its use the 5 case
summary based on the current ground set
of this quantity here which is kind of
like an exploit quantity and this
quantity here which is an explorer
quantity and so you could you know
you'll intimately recognize this as a
form of gcb where the upper confidence
bound is given by the square root of
this quantity V and then V is really
this outer well it's a sort of a sum of
sub modular products weighted sum
modular products weighted by C where C
is a covariance matrix what's computed
in the previous round and then mu is
essentially the estimates of the current
weight
okay so that's basically idea and in
fact since we're interested in primarily
now one of the things I want to mention
right away actually is that this
combinatorial problem is is difficult so
this is a this is a highly non sub
modular problem it's some of weighted
sambhaji function so the new part is
actually pretty easy but the difficult
part is the square root of V V is the
sum of weighted products and the weights
might be positive or might be negative
so what do we do well the first thing we
do and this is this is sort of the
strategies that we took to to this
problem and so well let's let's say
since since our goal is to sort of try
to learn the survivor function as
quickly as possible when it was as few
queries as possible let's consider an
explorer only setting where we ignore
you we only care about V and as a result
we can ignore the first term and get rid
of the square root you get rid of the
square root there we ignore this u
square roots gone and so there's no
trade-off I'm running out of time okay
sorry does it have to fit negative five
minutes or positive five minutes of time
yeah sure okay well I gotta use shiz
technique of talking backwards same time
I'm going to steal that joke for the
rest of eternity so so I let me let me
skip this so I'm just going to just say
that um okay so so here's the Explorer
only version and the Explorer version
actually can be seen as a form of active
learning but your active learning of a
submodular function using a form of
uncertainty sampling so you could serve
it turns out that this actually ends up
being the sea and the you turn out to be
the covariance matrix in the mean of a
Gaussian and where one assumes that the
feedback you get one of the user is
basically Gaussian with a particular
mean and the particular covariance which
is based on these parameters so the mean
actually ends up being the dot product
between the estimated mean here and and
the actual vector of the module
functions the vectors the major
components that we've got but the key
thing is that the this v function is now
a little bit easier so we don't have
some giant square root coupling
absolutely everything together square
roots on top of things when what's
inside is is not lies which is what this
is is a difficult thing to optimize so
it turns out that V right so this is
this is the problem we're particularly
interested in solving finding a max / v
of cardinality constrained it's a car
dolly concering maximization where v is
this sums and differences of products of
submodular functions so one of the
things that we found is that whenever
you treat a problem like this as a black
box namely you treat this as a black box
it becomes hopelessly in a box mobile
there's no hope of doing anything
associated with me as soon as you open
the black box and may be treated more
like a glass box it becomes the case set
there are there is some modularity
involved it's possible to get something
of some kind of approximation guarantee
indeed this happens to be the case an
hour in the current setting so we sort
of resorted to some earlier work that we
did which is basically optimizing the
difference of similar functions so to
any any such function suitability in
function can be represented the
difference between its sub modular
difference between two submodular
functions and the proof is actually
entire is trivial basically this it says
that you just take any arbitrary set
function add a massively scaled
submodular function and then subtract it
and then the function you want plus the
mass which scales to budget function
must be so much land then you're
subtracting it so it's trivia different
the challenge in all of these BF
difference of sub modular optimization
problems is in coming up with a natural
decomposition into a sub-module and
super modular problem which is sometimes
feasible I'm going to I'll just go to
this slide here it's sometimes feasible
for example when one uses the mutual
information of a side of random
variables it has a very natural
decomposition to a difference of entropy
entropy and conditional entropy but the
question is in this particular case is
there a natural decomposition and the
other thing to note is that it's not if
you treat V is a black box it's provably
hard to come up with the difference of
sub modular decomposition so it's not
like something we can root force produce
a difference if the module functions of
d but when i'm going to skip these two
slides because i'm running out of time
but basically the approach once you
actually have it in in the form of a
difference of submodular functions it's
possible to there's there's a set of
algorithms that we've worked on and
actually that work quite well for
repeatedly major izing and then
maximizing with some of mine rising and
maximizing with some major function and
the way this works essentially is that
you take this differences of modular
functions then you project it onto a
sub-module function you say maximize the
smart reform
minimize depending what you're doing and
then reproject and you repeat this
process of project and optimizing
projection optimize and that has led to
so much a super major procedure and the
super modular sub-module procedure and a
couple of other things okay so what I
what what we ended up doing then in this
particular case is we want to look at
this particular function here which is
kind of difficult because on one hand so
the seas the Koreans matrix might be
positive and negative right but on the
other hand that that actually doesn't
lead to us it's too too much difficulty
because that's what that's naturally
expressible as a difference the hard
part is the products but it turns out
due to some basically algebraic
manipulation it's possible to identify
the conditions where the products of sub
major functions for some of the
subclasses of sub modular functions that
were interested in namely the concave /
modular functions have expressions
either as submodular functions
themselves or as differences of some of
your functions so this is the kind of
results that we have so this is an
example of a case where it's a concave /
modular function the concave function is
really just X to the beta where beta is
some scalar between 0 and 1 and based on
some conditions is being is between 0
and 1 half there are cases where this
product is sub modular and if beta is
between one half and one there are cases
where the product is super modular so
that's sort of i'm not going to go into
this because like i said it's a lot of
algebra it's just sure this is true but
these are the kinds of results that
we've acquired for the these these roots
like functions another class of
functions that we've used a lot in in
practice is log of 1 plus functions
which have a stronger degree of
dimension returns as the values of the
module function gets larger so products
of those things
are sometimes not in terms of modular
and then lastly the probably to coverage
function which is oftentimes used in
things like blogs and Carl scarin folks
have used these kinds of functions
before these also often have natural d
conversations as different differences
okay so the one last thing I want to
mention to you because you're probably
all expecting a regret Brandon on
running out of time so I apologize but
the problem is that we we do have a
regret brown but it's not it's not worth
stating because it's a little bit
trivial basically it's the same regret
frond as you and guest room and
basically says that if it's possible for
us to optimize the v function exactly we
get a regret bound even though that's
the case that it's you know essentially
comment or bandits with 2 to the N arms
that's basically comparable to their
regrets up but what we're working on is
is saying okay well what if we can
approximate V so what if we can come up
with some sort of approximation and
guarantee on V and so that's where we've
introduced this new class of functions
called SS functions or sub modular super
modular functions and these functions
are basically defined not as the
difference of sub module functions but I
said in addition that the sub module and
a super modular function and we can
define curvature based on sub-module
function and this sort of corresponds to
the degree to which the sub-module
function is not modular modular
functions are generally fairly easy
nothing interacts and if the curvature
of the sub-module function curvatures
number between 0 and 1 is the curve
curvature of the function is 0 it's
modular if it's one so it's sort of the
hardest case and then we can sort of
define a form of curvature on a super
modular function which is defined
analogously and also corresponds to the
degree to which the superb modular
function is not modular so we have a
very recent result on DS style
optimization differences sub-module but
it's really a path style optimization of
these functions that if we do a
basically this major ization
minimization or ionization maximization
style approach we get a guarantee of the
following a worst-case guarantee for
this is for the cardinality constrained
maximization that's that's functions and
you might some of you might find it
familiar because if it's the case that G
is a modular function than cafe G the
curvature becomes zero and we get the
standard curvature based lower bound for
some other function maximization which
is better than the 1-1 at really
guarantee but what's new is the is the G
in here so what we're sort of working on
is then showing that these kinds of
guarantees translate into the regret
down now the other thing I wanted to
mention is that we do have some results
on these various different algorithms
but I showed you where what this shows
is the speed of learning the samaja
function and so this is done in a
variety of different settings the first
case we have three synthetic data sets
and then one image civilization real
data set and also in the machine
learning data set this is this is the
last slide so sorry so um so what this
shows is as a function of number of
summaries that have has been generated
and then queried by the user how well
does the resulting performance of a
summarized learn to summarize some other
function do relative to the ground
troops sorts of modular functions and
this active so the active comet oriole
sampling approach is the one that in all
of these cases this is just binary
feedback so this is basically where we
have a threshold where which is
basically fifty percent of the top value
of the sum of the truths of major
function and basically the threshold is
binary which the thumbs-up or
thumbs-down whether or not it's a good
summary or bad sorry and was this with
this very very limited feedback about
the ground truth we're learning so logic
function better than I guess what what
these results are showing is the red
result is the pure Explorer case and
these other results here are allowing a
little bit
exploit depending on the value of alpha
alpha being larger means that you do
more explore so in some sense the red is
alpha 2 equals infinity and may that's
not so surprising but this is for more
like red scale feedback and then so
here's the result with real image
summarization again with up-down
feedback and you can see when we have
enough summaries it's does seem to be
doing better I should also mention
another baseline there's random
summaries and the random summaries are
all over the map but it's doing better
than the best random summaries on
average and then also for for machine
learning this is for a speech
recognition problem using subsets
actually 1% of the training data and
training on the proper one percent and
coming up with trying to learn as a
larger function that's good at selecting
a subset of this training set so that
when you train on it you get a good
recognizer and it's showing the accuracy
and again using this active comet or
sampling procedure which is a fully
explorative algorithm does better than
these other Explorer exploit procedures
so I think you know this is a work in
progress i have to admit but it pretends
well to being able to learn a silagra
function without actually having to deal
with the burden of generating some rates
off beforehand so that's basically it
lets the talk I'm sorry for going late
and when I stop for questions
[Applause]
authentic attention is part of all
because of the square root yeah well
there's other results I didn't mention
some but it turns out that even if we
add the exploit turn back in so we have
an approximation guarantee that if we
take theirs if we square the exploit
term and remove the square root of the
Explorer term and we solve that with
some guarantee we have another guarantee
of the original problem so we can
actually deal with that diploma the
problem is that can that so the
guarantee of solving V or some variants
of V or square root of V or square root
of V Plus exploit that if something
sense gives we do have multiplicative
proclamations for that but we don't yet
have this regret Browns is that that
approximate solving of that doesn't yet
translate to the big red phone so that's
really where the work needs to be done
but but that's that issue is ok I think
but that's it's a bit those are
non-trivial approximation so strong as
when they sermon some is the benefit
comes from the fact that you do only
exploration and then optimize at the end
so it's most don't have so it can be
more aggressive an exploration yeah and
it varies yeah so so in the experiments
we did try larger values of alpha those
were the best values of alpha but for
some reason when alpha gets big there's
it never got as good as it's doing fully
explorative search and so the benefit
must be because all you're doing is
explore which is you're trying to learn
the function quickly as possible but
you're never trying to exploit and that
I think that's a sort of you know that's
really where it's online learning it's
supposed to online producing a summary
the benchmark to compare yeah obviously
you just get feedback for the full set
or what they are one of the curves where
you actually observe the noisy estimates
of the modular game no that's not in the
benchmarks it's always the case when
it's feedback everybody gets feedback on
this all set but i guess that i mean
that's that's something that should be
in the slot I agree
and I think that that they should be in
the flat or not but they because it's a
much more feedback you would expect them
to be better but we were not really that
interested in that setting though
because that's just not not feasible for
the task we're trying to solve
[Applause]